E
PICKUPS THERE, TECHNOLOGICAL
PROBLEMS FOR US TO DEAL WITH.
BUT LET'S GET TO THE STORY, THE
TOP STORY WE ARE FOLLOWING HERE,
IT IS BELIEVED THAT THE WORST
DISASTER INVOLVING MIGRANTS
TRIED TO CROSS THE ENGLISH
CHANNEL.
AT LEAST 27 PEOPLE, INCLUDING 5
CHILDREN AND A CHILD DIED OFF
THE COAST OF COLLIE, NORTHERN
FRANCE, WEDNESDAY.
THIS AFTER A BOAT TRYING TO
REACH BRITAIN CAPSIZED IN THE
FRIGID WATERS.
2 MIGRANTS WHO SURVIVED ARE
BEING TREATED FOR HYPOTHERMIA,
FRENCH PRESIDENT EMMANUEL
MACRON, AND BRITISH PRIME
MINISTER BORIS JOHNSON SAY THEY
WILL STEP UP EFFORTS TO PREVENT
MIGRANTS FROM MAKING THESE
DANGEROUS CROSSINGS.
CNN'S JIM BETTERMENT IS
FOLLOWING DEVELOPMENTS, HE
JOINS US NOW FROM PARIS.
AND DISTRESSING STORY, WHAT IS
THE LATEST ON WHAT EXACTLY
HAPPENED, AND ONE OF THE EU K
AND FRANCINE ABOUT THIS?
>> WELL THEY ARE BASICALLY
ACCUSING EACH OTHER OF
RESPONSIBILITY IN THIS AFFAIR,
AS YOU SAID, ONE OF THE WORST
INCIDENTS OF THIS KIND IN THE
ENGLISH CHANNEL IF NOT BE WORSE.
THEY REVISED THE DEATH TOLL
SLIGHTLY DOWNWARDS TO 27,
DOESN'T MAKE IT ANY BETTER.
BOTH SIDES ARE ACCUSING THE
OTHER OF HAVING SOME
RESPONSIBILITY THERE.
THE BRITISH SUGGESTED THAT
PERHAPS THERE SHOULD BE SOME
KIND OF JOINT PATROLS ALONG THE
FRENCH COAST, AND THE FRENCH
ARE SAYING THAT THE BRITISH
SHOULD STEP UP THEIR EFFORTS,
AND CHANGE THEIR POLICIES TO
MAKE IT LESS ATTRACTIVE FOR
MIGRANTS TO TRY THIS CROSSING.
AND IN TERMS OF PRACTICALITY,
AFTER THAT CONVERSATION BETWEEN
BORIS JOHNSON AND EMMANUEL
MACRON DURING THE NIGHT LAST
NIGHT, THE FOREIGN MINISTER OF
FRANCE AND THE HOME SECRETARY
--
TALK TODAY TO SEE WHAT THEY CAN
DO IN THE PRACTICAL SENSE, TO
STOP THIS FLOW.
IN TERMS OF DETAILS, THEY'VE
ARRESTED A 5TH PERSON, AS FOR
RESPONSIBILITY IN CREATING THE
ATMOSPHERE FOR THESE MIGRANTS
TO COME ACROSS.
THE PERSON THAT WAS ARRESTED
WELDERS AND GERMAN, AND
APPARENTLY THE RUBBER RAFT THAT
WOULD HAVE SANK WAS A GERMAN
MANUFACTURER, A GERMAN SALE.
SO THERE IS SOME CONNECTION
THERE TO GERMANY.
PRESIDENT MACRON SAID HE WANTS
TO WIDEN OUT THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT THIS TO HIS EUROPEAN
PARTNERS, BECAUSE HE BELIEVES
THEY BEAR SOME RESPONSIBILITY
IN THESE CRIMINAL GANGS THAT
MIGRANTS ARE FALLING VICTIM TO,
AND TO THE PAST WHO SOUND THE
MIGRANTS OUT INTO THE DANGEROUS
CONDITIONS OUT ON THE CHANNEL,
AND IN AND WE CAN SEE THE
RESULT OF THAT.
>> YEAH, JUST ABSOLUTELY
HORRENDOUS, TIM BITTERMANN
JOINING US LIVE FROM PARIS,
MANY THANKS.
AND JOINING US NOW FROM LONDON,
IS TO HIT PASHA, SENIOR
COORDINATOR AT THE
INTERNATIONAL ORGANIZATION FOR
MIGRATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TALKING
WITH US.
27 PEOPLE CONFIRMED DEAD IN
THIS TRAGEDY, 5 WOMEN AND A
LITTLE GIRL INCLUDED IN THE
DEAD.
IN THIS ATTEMPTED CROSSING OF
THE ENGLISH CHANNEL IN THESE
FREEZING TEMPERATURES.
AND THE LEADERS OF BRITAIN IN
FRANCE APPEAR TO BE BLAMING
EACH OTHER, WHO DO YOU BLAME
FOR THIS?
>> THIS IS NOT ABOUT TO
COUNTRIES, ON THE CHANNEL, BUT
I LARGER UNIVERSAL ISSUE, WE
HAD SINCE 2014, WE STARTED
COUNTING 45,000 DEATHS ACROSS
THE WORLD.
LAST YEAR ALONE FOR HALF
THOUSAND PEOPLE DIED ACROSS THE
WORLD, LAST WEEK 35 PEOPLE DIED
LEAVING LIBYA ON A BOAT FROM
THE MARRIAGE RAINY AND, THAT
WASN'T REPORTED AS MUCH AS THIS
ONE WAS.
AND THIS JUST SHOWS THE GLOBAL
SCALE OF THE PROBLEM.
AND WE REALLY HAVE TO ENSURE
THAT WE CAN TAKE A UNIVERSAL
COOPERATIVE RESPONSE.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT,
BECAUSE FRENCH PRESIDENT
EMMANUEL MACRON SAID HE WILL
NOT LET THE ENGLISH CHANNEL
BECOME A GRAVEYARD, AND THE UK
PRIME MINISTER BORIS JOHNSON
SAYS HE'S SHOCKED AND APPALLED.
AND WANTS TO STEP UP EFFORTS TO
DEAL WITH THIS MIGRANT CRISIS,
HE AND MACRON HAVE AGREED TO
PUT IN PLACE JOINT EFFORTS TO
PREVENT MIGRANT CROSSINGS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THAT MEANS,
EXACTLY.
SO THEY'LL STOP THESE CROSSINGS,
BUT THAT DOESN'T SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM, DOESN'T?
>> NOT AT ALL, NOT AT ALL.
A DISPROPORTIONATE USE OF
VARIOUS, PUTTING UP THE BORDERS,
IS NOT GOING TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM ON ITS OWN.
WHAT WE NEED IS, WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THE BUSINESS BOTTLE,
BY GETTING MORE ADEQUATE, SAFE
LEGAL ROUTES AND PATHWAYS.
LET'S BEAR IN MIND THE GLOBAL
CONTEXT HERE.
THERE ARE UP TO 26 MILLION
REFUGEES IN THIS WORLD, THE
VAST MAJORITY ARE LIVING AND
STAYING IN COUNTRIES
NEIGHBORING THE COUNTRIES THAT
THEY LEFT.
VERY FEW MAKE IT ACROSS TO
WESTERN COUNTRIES LIKE THE UK
AND FRANCE.
AND SO WHAT WE NEED, IS WE NEED
TO HAVE COUNTRIES LIKE THE UK
AND FRANCE, REALLY STEPPING UP
THE PROTECTION REGIMES TO ALLOW
AND FACILITATE THOSE WHO ARE
ENTITLED TO PROTECTION TO BE
ABLE TO ENTER.
>> SO, WHAT IS THE SITUATION
FOR MANY OF THESE MIGRANTS, AND
ASYLUM SEEKERS ON THE GROUND,
AND HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT HERE?
>> SO, IF WE LOOK AT THE
NATIONALITIES OF THOSE WHO DIED,
COUNTED FROM YESTERDAY, THE
MAJORITY WERE SAUDI ARABIAN,
SOME SOMALI NATIONALS, SO THAT
IMMEDIATELY POINTS TO THAT
THOSE WERE WEALTHY COUNTRIES OF
PERSECUTION.
WHAT WE NEED TO DO, IS WE NEED
TO BE WORKING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE FLEEING
THOSE COUNTRIES CAN GET OUT, TO
RESETTLEMENT REGIMES, BUT THEY
CAN GET ACCESS TO HUMANITARIAN
PATHWAYS THAT ALLOW THEM TO
STAY IN THESE COUNTRIES.
ANOTHER THING TO BEAR IN MIND,
IS THAT SOME OF THEM HAVE --
FAMILY REUNIFICATION IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
WE SHOULD NOT BE CLOSING DOWN
THE FAMILY COMMUNICATION
CHANNELS, AND WE SHOULD BE
OPENING THEM UP.
>> AND WHAT ABOUT THESE PEOPLE
WHO ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR PUTTING
THE MIGRANTS ON THESE BOATS.
WHAT SHOULD HAPPEN TO THEM?
--
>> WELL THEY ARE PART OF A
DANGEROUS CRIMINAL NETWORK,
WHERE THERE ARE TRAFFICKING
PEOPLE.
THOSE WHO ARE USING THE
SMUGGLERS HAVE NO OPTION TO USE
SMUGGLERS, THAT'S WHERE THE
BUSINESS COMES FROM.
IF WE COULD TAKE THAT AWAY FROM
THEM, AND IF WE CAN TAKE TRYING
TO OPEN UP THESE LEGAL AVENUES,
THAT HAS TO BE THE ANSWER.
SO STATES HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE A PROPORTIONATE RESPONSE,
WHERE THEY ARE ENSURING THAT
THESE PATHWAYS ARE OPEN.
BUT AS I SAID, WE HAVE THOSE
AVENUES TO DO THAT.
AND THE NUMBERS OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE SEEKING PROTECTION IN THE
UK, IS ACTUALLY QUITE SMALL,
THE KEY WAS IN 2012 WE'VE HAD
VERY LOW NUMBER SINCE THEN.
16,000 PEOPLE GOT PROTECTION
AND ACCESS TO ASYLUM IN THE UK,
LAST YEAR.
IF YOU COMPARE THAT TO THE
GLOBAL RESPONS